aneddoto divertente prima di cominciare
il video volevo giocare a dr
quindi ho comprato su steam però ho
sbagliato prima di coprendo ho comprato
doors ho comprato un altro gioco è
sbagliato a scrivere non era quello è
buttato 5 euro bella tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo video sono favi jade
ed oggi siamo su porte e basse c'è porte
si chiama così le porte
va bene ma non c'è audio in questo gioco
sono io che sono sordo movimento james
air ajo salvo la parte ok tutti i puzzle
sono una porta che porta del boe con
tutte le altre forze portano alla morte
va bene a far chiari ma in italiano non
lo sapevano loro lo so solo io
beh ragazzi siamo sul gioco dove ci sono
delle porte questo penso fosse capito
quella è una porta credo il bacon e
fantastico anche io lo penso quando vado
in america lo mangia con easy a spedire
che mangia il bacon li porti dove sono
esattamente c'è un albero bruttissimo a
ci sono due bene la porta a porta al
bacon nell'altra porta alla morte solo
una porta e corretta
questo porta a porta al bacon l'altra
volta porta alla morte per niente non
sono capace abbiamo capito che non è il
mio gioco questo è questo ciò che volevo
fare io ed a quel punto mi sono accorto
che ho sbagliato a comprare il gioco e
quindi ho comprato poi l'altro che era
quello che volevo effettivamente fare
quindi fantastico magari era meglio
colori prima però ho anche questo c'è un
menù però almeno sotto la scritta porta
c'è una porta quindi i soldi benz per il
caso allo einstein ma guarda
conoscendomi casual va benissimo
l'audio sono io stupido non c'è audion i
giochi di porte hanno associato il nome
al minimo
porca eva allora ragazzi siamo su un
gioco di sono bravissimi ad aprire le
porte la portavo la posso aprire a si
può aprire tante porte posso aprire
all'inizio troppe volte aiuto e poi c'è
un nuovo questa roba
cosa succede ma non erano molto più
belle le altre ma non volevo venire qua
non entrare ma va a terapia senta signor
angelo della morte non volevo offenderlo
approccio ha scritto non entrare se vuoi
che io non entri devi scrivere entra
pure è uscita la porta numero 1 uscita
la porta numero due uscite a parte
novello tre uscite la porta numero
beh chiarissimo io comunque tra tutte
rimarrei su questa perché la cosa che mi
ha intrigato di più la porta col colore
g.col colore giallo no perché si gioca
in inglese ma nella 1 perché
specialmente non è la uno va bene ha
cambiato colore ogni volta cambia colore
colore r red
qui rosso ha quindi g era verde ok
chiaro sicuramente è un gioco di
trabocchetti che bello uscita la porta
colore 3 sulla porta colore tre era
quasi chiaro che la risposta non era
questa però ok non ci è successo a mi fa
ripartire dall'inizio ogni volta e c'è
poi che non esistono ma che cos'è che ci
è scusata che non ho capito uscita la
porta numero 4 è uscita la porta numero
4 è scemo questa si punta alle porte è
uscita la parte numero 2 ha sempre
questa era non mi devi [ __ ]
no invece sbagliato perché vi fa
ripartire dall'inizio adesso la portò
numero 3 è morto non lo trasmette questa
allora sei scemo ma come uscita la porta
numero 4
1234 questa è no no e allora decise fai
da te regole le fai tu fai tutto tu non
lo so non ho capito porto numero 3
perché era questo ha istituito adesso di
terni che mi spieghi perché questa è la
porta numero 3 come 1222 non 323 perché
dove lo vedi il 3 dove minchia style 3
questa è una c abc ah ho capito uscita
alla porta numero 5
queste sono figure quindi il cerchio va
leggero triangolare tra quadrato re4
questo uno due tre quattro cinque che
bello essere intelligenti mica come
pietro riuscita volta al numero 3 ok a
gran trabocchetto dove vedere come sono
scritti i numeri va bene questo secondo
me è un due e questo secondo me oltre
proviamo
mia madre mi ha fatto malissimo
portanumero tre allora non è questa
abbiamo detto quindi è questa
ecco bene uscita la porta numero errore
cosa vuol dire porta numero errore ci
deve essere qualcosa in una di queste
porte che non è come sembra
cosa c'è di strano in ste volte sono
tutte uguali jolo bene non ho capito
niente uscita la porta al numero 4 1 2 3
e 4 non vorrei però essere [ __ ] che
rinunci al check point da qualche parte
perché devo iniziare sempre da 04 questa
hai visto come sono bravo nelle cose di
ingegno sì però non mi puoi far
ripartire veramente all'inizio e per
l'amore di gesù ti prego se c'è un tasto
di salvataggio perché non è che posso
fare il gioco da capo ogni volta che
sbaglio c'è capite che non è umana una
cosa uscita la porta al numero 2 adesso
numero 2 quindi questa ok ma non c'è
manca il card eccolo uscite alla porta
al numero 3
perché c'è un cubo con un piccone tra
che minecraft va bene qualsiasi altra
delle soluzioni giusta tranne la 3
quindi da uno hai visto come sono
fortunato quando tiro a caso sulle rocce
veloce per terra 1234 ma va a cagare ma
ci sono delle soluzioni incredibili
porta ancora numero errore ma basta
vabbè un labirinto non ci sto vedendo
niente di sbagliato io quindi non lo so
non capisco potrebbe essere qualsiasi di
queste ragano no capito dove dovrebbe
stare l'errore cesta quale errore ma non
ha senso a quella che passa in mezzo la
colonna non va bene proviamo a tre e
mezza la colonna ci vuoi passare ma io
che cosa li so io cosa nessuno 50 per
cento di probabilità perfetto c'è poi
cos'è e cosa c'è di strano nel lavoro
non lo so quello che sapete come si fa
chiuso qui cosa faccio aiuto ho fatto
tutto sto casino per i tornare qua e poi
c'è una porta rossa ok avrò finito
questa parte devo finire le tutte sei
una volta che saranno finite tutte sei
avevano finito il gioco cosa che non
farò mai perché in un episodio
impossibile e non penso di poterci
tornare a un altro episodio perché la
mia mente è già a dura prova
oltre alla matematica delle elementari
non sono mai andato proviamo questo che
è molto verde mi sembra carino uscita
dalla porta con la figura 3 pentagon
forse alla geometria sono arrivato alle
medie uscita dalla porta con la figura
su e quindi square quindi quadrato circo
triangolo pentagono square uscita con la
porta con il cerchio non tutti i
pannelli possono essere presi per veri
va bene o pentagono cerchio triangolo
questa è l'unica che non hanno detto i
cartelli quindi sarà questa la mia
logica da ornitorinco morto uscita la
porta numero 1 st volta proviamo
ok quindi era questo qua il cartello
gicos non ci potrei arrivare con la
logica dove andare solo a culo in
possibile uscita dalla porta con la
figura ci circle errore numero uno
numero 3 al 14 il numero cinque sono i
lati 15 e circolo quindi numero uno alla
porta giusta o beige
alle volte dico cagati incredibile alle
volte azzecco subito il ragionamento non
so come è uscita la portanumero uomo
sono tutte tratteggiate tranne questa
sarà questa bene uscita con la porta con
la figura triangolo che è questa perché
sono intrecciati i ferri ferri
l'ornitorinco giusto che cura ragazza
danno benissimo non so come uscita a
portare la figura cerchio aggiunto roth
e staccate qui a per terra e questa va
bene porta con la figura punto
interrogativo allora pentagono e il
pentagono c'è quadrato e quadrato c'è
cuadrado cuadrado non certo dovrebbe
essere il triangolo in teoria dovrebbe
essere triangolo ma forse non in pratica
quindi non entrò subito perché se non ce
la farò mai più ad arrivare qua quanto
manca al finale e non tantissimo
triangola ci prova perfetta
e vabbè cos'è triangolo sempre ok
andiamo sempre sul triangolo bene ce
l'ho fatta ce l'ho fatta sotto anche la
seconda certamente anziché una volta
sono stato bravissimo
cavolo ci credo sono fiero di me stesso
ma apriamo questa mi sembra la più
carina color g green è la prima
ormai io sono entrato nel mood però non
è così semplice però mentre grafici ma
soprattutto per il porto che devi
ripartire ogni volta da zero che palle
uscita dalla porta colore uno è il
colore quello che c'era all'inizio
ultimamente sono stato abbastanza
intelligente tutto in un colpo bova al
molo detto fisco il video quando farò
pinete exit the door with the colour di
colore blu quindi o è questa che però è
colorata di giallo ma è una b o è questa
che il colore blu però è una ypsilon io
credo che sia questa perfetto cos'è sta
roba qua i giochi per bambini aiuto
eccomi centro ma un sacco in questi
uscita dalla porta col colore 3a con
quello che ha solo tre colori in questo
caso è il giallo gli altri sono più di
tre mini giallo
molto bene uscita da una porta all
errore finalmente tornato con lo
schifoso l'aido bene d'or un indizio
questo
ragazzi se uniamo il mio blog con questo
cerco in mezzo sembra il simbolo di
topolino quindi ragazzi direi che
possiamo arrivare quasi alla conclusione
se non riesco però io sapete cosa vi
dico che nella vita alle volte il 25 per
cento di probabilità funziona e sapete
che vi dico vai vai vai così si porca
vacca singh così ragazzi spero che vi
sia piaciuto io sono contentissimo di
aver evitato dimostrazione di sapere
perché me la cavo nei giochi glow gis tc
molto più di quanto pensiate di
ragazzoni spero che vi sia piaciuto ma
mi piace anche perché mi sono le
statistiche e noi ci vediamo al prossimo
vito da ragazzi
[Musica]